翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Keisuke Yamashita
今日は 新たな一歩について
お話ししたいと思います
正確に言いますと「新たな一歩」
という言葉についてです
いい言葉ですよね
１回ぐらいは こういう言葉
考えたことがあると思います
何かきっかけがないかな？
新しい一歩を踏み出したいな
でもきっかけがない
っていうことも よくありますよね
新たな一歩を踏み出したい
でもきっかけがない
一体なぜなんでしょう
ここに何か秘密があるような気がします
ところで 私たちは成功物語が大好きです
有名人とか スポーツ選手の大活躍を聞く
「元気をもらった」
「明日の仕事を頑張れそうだ」
って思ったりします
ところが 何日か経つと
また元に戻ってしまう
あれ？ ちょっとまた元気が無くなった
それで次の成功物語を聞く
また元気をもらった
「よし！頑張ろう」
でもまたちょっとすると
元に戻ってしまう
そのとき 私たちはこう思ったりとかします
私は彼らとは違うから 平凡だから
彼らとは違うんだよ
だから一歩踏み出せないんだ
って思ったりとかします
ところで一歩ってなんでしょう
実際に歩くわけじゃないですよね
もちろん喩えです
そのきっかけがないっていうのは
一体どんな意味なんでしょう
私はここに落とし穴がある
そんな気がするんです
新たな一歩を踏み出したい
だけど きっかけがないな
それは落とし穴にはまってること
じゃないのかなって思いました
私 仕事でビジネス関係のセミナーとか
研修に呼ばれることがよくあります
こんなことがありました
遠くの小さな町から依頼を受けて
「元気の出る中小企業の事例を
いっぱい紹介してください」って言われました
「わかりました
よそでうまくいった話がありますから
いっぱい持っていきます」
って勇んで出かけました
電車で駅に着いて 駅を一歩出ると
豊かな田園風景が広がっていました
見渡したところビルがない
会社の看板らしきものが見えない
お店が１つ２つポツポツとある
あれ？なんか私
間違ったような気がするって思いました
また別の機会にこんなことがありました
あるデパートで「社員研修やってください」
って言われました
「マネジメントの初歩の初歩を
教えてください」
「わかりました 本当に簡単な
初歩の初歩ですね わかりました」
っていうふうに準備して行きました
ガラッと部屋を開けて受講者の皆さんを見て
あれ？っと思いました
私のイメージでは これからデパートの
経営管理を担う若手社員の研修だ
スーツを着てネクタイを締めて
という方たちだと思っていたんですが
ネクタイをしている
そもそも 男性が１人もいない
あれ？ どうやらこれは
販売員の皆さんではないだろうか
ちょっと違う準備をしてきてしまいました
非常に焦りました
こんなことが本当によくあるんです
でもその時に私はこう思いました
一歩の見方ってどうやら
人によって違うらしいな
ここに何か秘密があるんじゃないかな
っていうふうに思いました
じゃあ 落とし穴って一体何なんでしょう
多分こうじゃないかなと思いました
大きすぎる一歩
まぁ 一歩っていうのは喩えなんですけれど
一歩踏み出せないということは
なにかその一歩が大きすぎて
今の自分ではとても踏み出せないな
だからきっかけがないと思ってしまう
今の自分にとって
大きすぎる一歩が頭の中によぎると
何かそのイメージがあるだけで
前に出ることが怖くなってしまう
きっとそうなんじゃないかなって
いうふうに思いました
新たな一歩っていうのは
人生の節目だけにあるわけじゃないと思います
人生のうち ２度か３度しか
ないものじゃなくて
日々の仕事であるとか日常生活でも
よくこんなようなことは起きると思います
「調子が悪いな」とか
「なんかやる気がでない」
「なんか停滞感を感じるな」
っていうことは頻繁にあると思います
これも新たな一歩を
踏み出せないっていう場合に
当てはまるんじゃないでしょうか
私はその時には 何か大きなものが
頭によぎっていて
踏み出せなくなっている
そんな気がします
じゃあどうしたらいいんでしょう？
実は簡単ですね
一歩が大きすぎるわけですから
歩幅を小さくすればいいだろう
って思いました
要するに大きすぎる一歩
十歩も百歩も千歩も先を見てしまっている
大きな遠くの物を
見てしまっているから踏み出せない
だったら 近くの小さなものを見ればいいな
って単純に思いました
じゃあどこまで小さくすれば踏みだせるかな
どんどんどんどん手前に持ってきたら
今すぐ何かできることを
やったらいいんじゃないか
一番小さいことってなんだろうって
思ったんですけど
例えばこの場でできそうなこと
深呼吸ぐらいかなって思いました
どうです？ せっかくですから
一歩踏み出してみましょうか
（笑）
背筋を伸ばしてください
じゃあ 大きく息を吸ってください
はい ゆっくり吐いてください
いかがでしょう
何か新しい気分が
湧いてこないですか？
つまり一番小さな一歩だったらば
誰でも踏み出せるんだって思うんです
リフレッシュしたこの気分で
次に何を思うか
ここからはそれぞれの方が
違うわけですよね
だって歩幅が違いますから
それぞれの置かれている状況とか
事情が違いますから
そのときの事情に合わせて
一歩踏み出せばいいんだ
今日踏み出せる何かを考えればいいんだ
例えば何があるでしょう
散らかった部屋を片付けたい でもちょっと
これ 今の自分にはハードルが高いな
１週間ぐらいかかりそうだ
でも机の上ぐらいだったらいけるかな
本箱の１列分くらいならいけるかな
みたいな感じ
ちょっとしたことですけれど
今の自分の歩幅に合ってる
やる気がない状態の気持ちにも合ってる
こんなものが あるんじゃないでしょうか
これが実は一歩踏み出す
コツじゃないかと思うんです
じゃあ 一歩踏みだしたら
次は一体どうしたらいいのでしょう
これも簡単ですよね
歩きに喩えているわけですから
次も踏み出すということですね
どんどん踏み出す
一歩踏み出した
今 先ほど皆さんで深呼吸しました
さぁ 今日 夜までに
新たな一歩を何か考えなきゃ
今日 TEDxが終わるまでに何か考えよう
これも新たな一歩ですよね
次のチャレンジを制限時間の間に考える
朝起きた 今日はやる気がでない でも
朝ごはんを終えるまでには 済ますまでには
今日のチャレンジを１個考えることを
最初の一歩にしてみよう とか
簡単な一歩はいろいろあると思います
でも大事なのは実際に
次々と踏み出すことじゃないかと思います
今の自分の精一杯の歩幅で一歩出る
それだけでも何かが
変わるんじゃないかと思います
そして踏み出し続けること
それは まぁ言い換えれば
行動の習慣がある
ということじゃないでしょうか
自分で何か踏み出すのものを決めて
実際小さく踏み出す
小さな行動ですよね
毎日毎日
何歩も踏み出す
それは行動が習慣になったって
ことじゃないでしょうか
そうすると 少しずつ何かが変わって
くるんじゃないかなっていう気がします
毎日毎日 一歩を踏み出す
何度も踏み出す
そうすると少しずつ
歩幅が大きくなってくるかもしれない
自分が決めたことをやり遂げる
ちっちゃなことです
でも確実に手応えがある
ちょっとしたチャレンジを成功させた
今日は３回も成功させた
そこが自信につながる
今ちょっと行動して結果が出る
自信が持てる
そうしたことを毎日毎日繰り返すことが
大事なんじゃないかな
というふうに思うんです
例えば昔すごく大きな
成果を収めた 大成功した
３年も５年も10年も前に
でも ここ１年間ぐらい 調子悪いな
停滞しているなっていう場合
自信が持てるでしょうか
たぶん自信っていうのは今日
一歩踏み出したことによって
得られるものじゃないかな
っていうふうに思います
昨日踏み出した一歩は
もう終わってますから
今日はまた新たな一歩を
踏み出さないといけない
そんなふうに思います
一歩踏み出すことをやめたら
その途端に
自信が消えてしまうんじゃないかと思います
ところで どうにもならないこと
っていうのはありますね
「いやぁ 私はいろいろと事情がありまして
どうにもならないんですよ
だから きっかけがないんです」とか
でも このどうにもならないことっていうのも
大きすぎる一歩じゃないでしょうか
今日どうにもならないこと
でも 事情は皆さんいろいろありますよね
何の事情もない方って
いらっしゃらないんじゃないでしょうか
そして 同じ事情や条件を抱えてるという人は
２人といないような気がします
各人各様の事情を抱えている
だからその事情の中での
一歩があるはずなんです
例えば 健康状態が悪くて
寝たきりの人にとってみれば
起き上がるということですら
大きな一歩なのかもしれない
私たちにとって当たり前でも
偉人だとか有名なスポーツ選手が
簡単にできるようなことは
私たちにとっては難しい
でも私たちにとっての
チャレンジっていうのがあるはずだ
そんなふうに思います
どうにもならないことに気を取られるのは
時間の無駄だと思います
今できることに
集中した方がいいんじゃないか
新たな一歩は
どんな状態でも踏み出せる
深呼吸さえできれば
次の大きな一歩は考えつきますよね
深呼吸もできないときは
ちょっとまた検討しましょう
さて こうして 一歩を踏み出していくと
ものの見方が変わりますよね
少しずつ歩幅が広くなってくる
すると いろいろなものが見えてくる
違った景色が見える
今まではちょっと無理かなぁって
思っていたことが
ひょっとしたらできるんじゃないの？
っていうふうに見えてくる
これは夢だな こんな夢持ってるんだけど
ちょっと自分にはかなわないな
だから夢なんだ
だけど 小さな一歩を積み重ねていくと
いつかそれが目標になるかもしれない
でも 最初の一歩がなければ
夢は夢のままで終わる
そんな気がします
そこで 私からの提案です
新たな一歩を踏み出すためには
きっかけなんかいりません
今すぐ小さな一歩を踏み出しましょう
（拍手）